Hilary Duff speaking out after it was
announced Aaron Carter's unfinished
Memoir is hitting the shelves I just
want to be the best at what I do calling
the move a heartless money grab
Hi how are you for Hillary the situation
is personal she dated Aaron when both
their stars were on the rise we met at
my birthday party now less than a week
after Aaron's death Hillary's really sat
his Memoir that the late singer never
finished is still moving forward
in a statement to ET she says quote
there's a publisher that seems to be
recklessly pushing A book out to
capitalize on this tragedy without
taking appropriate time or care to fact
check the validity of his work Hillary
not holding back continues quote in no
way do I condone shedding any light on
what is so obviously an uninformed
heartless money grab I'm very proud of
her she's gone a long way as Hillary
sees it the timing speaks for itself she
says quote to water down Aaron's life
story to what seems to be unverified
click bait for profit is disgusting
I made the backlash Aaron's publisher is
responding a rep tells E.T in a
statement quote certain people in the
public eye don't want some of the
stories Aaron tells in his book to come
to light that doesn't make them any less
true or newsworthy I love making music
it's definitely my happy play following
News Aaron was found dead in his
California home Hillary shared a
touching tribute for Aaron I'm deeply
sorry that life was so hard for you and
that you had to struggle in front of the
whole world you had a charm that was
absolutely effervescent boy did my
teenage self love you deeply
[Music]
the post got tons of attention including
from Lindsay Lohan I had this like love
triangle with Hillary and Lindsay I know
you liked Hilary Duff's tribute and her
post on Instagram I mean you guys all
really came up together can you speak a
little bit on that kind of unique Bond
and you know the reaction you have when
you see news like that especially as you
know part of this generation of these
young Stars you know my heart goes out
to his family and may He rest in peace
and God bless him and
yeah just a lot of love there I went
through some hard times some difficult
things this comes on the heels of new
details being shared about Aaron's final
days
what I need is people to
understand that I'm human
and I make mistakes just like every
other human in this world his toxicology
reports yet to be released but we've
learned Aaron missed a therapy
appointment the night before he died and
the LA County Fire Department confirmed
to E.T that a welfare check was made for
him on September 20th to be honest when
I got there the day the incident
happened
there was no friends over there
I was really surprised it was just me
and Melanie and Melanie families you
know a few people but people I used to
see him every day in his house on his
face time nobody was there
that's why it's kind of concerning me
what happened
[Music]